now I think you guys are pretty good at
this so I'm just going to figure out one
example draw out a few important details
you want to pay attention to and then
I'm gonna move on okay so let's have a
look at for instance exercise 5c
question - Part C looks like this okay
so pretty standard result it's not gonna
take us long to actually prove it yeah a
couple of things to notice the idea is
that you want to go from one side all
the way to another okay
that's preferable for taking one side
and going to something point and doing
the other one and doing the same okay
the analogy all I have in my head is
kind of like suppose you ring up to get
a taxied because you're feeling like
spending a lot of money anyway if you
want to catch a taxi you're like you
call them up and you say how would I get
from calling food to say Castle Hill
okay so that's about 15 minutes drive
not long so it's not gonna break the
bank now suppose I say to you they you
know the guy says yeah sure that's fine
I'll meet you at west pennant hills
which is between
so you're like I wanted you to take me
from A to B not meet me at some weirdo
spud the middle which I have no
interested I'm come on it's been healed
really yes
okay the West Wing there's a lovely
place my name won't sit there anyway
that's the analogy I have in my hair
don't don't take both things to some
kind of third alternate even though it
might make it might feel more sensible
to simplify both sides and then show
that they're equal to each other okay
just to give you a sort of more
mathematical example right suppose I
wanted to prove to you that 2 was equal
to just yeah okay so let's do this shall
we okay inside if I multiply that by 0
which is a legitimate mathematical
operation it's 0 if I think right inside
I can do the same operation so I'm
awesome right yeah turns out I'm not so
awesome so mathematically you actually
have some problems with it ok so when
you've got a proof like this pick a side
and then go all the way from that to the
other side okay now which side do you
pick the more complicated one okay
because our brains are built for
simplification and that's what I've been
training you for last four and a half
years right so here it's actually kind
of a 50/50 because that looks gross but
this has a weirdo reciprocal function
you know okay my head I actually go from
the right hand side okay so that's what
I'm gonna do if you wanna stop at the
left that's one right an ounce and then
a nice easy strategy especially in this
one because what you've got on the left
hand side is in fundamental functions
it's in the signs and causes note ants
but you get the idea just bring
everything back down to what it should
be equal to in terms of signs in
constant ants so SEC is the reciprocal
for cause
and if you have trouble remembering
those just think about the three
reciprocal functions namely SEC Kosek
and hot and just look at the third
letter okay I don't know if you ever
been shown that before so this is what
I'm cause this is what I'm saying this
is one of town okay nice is it anyway
what I'm cos squared so I guess what we
should do is put them on a common
denominator so that's going to be one on
because we're minus cos squared yeah you
can see where it's going right so I've
got 1 minus cos squared on cos squared
but with the Pythagorean identity right
namely closed squared plus sine squared
is 1 you can simply sum that straight
for this okay so that's where I get some
right now this is a pretty simple proof
right 1 2 3 4 lines
barely okay and therefore because you
know what the result is and maybe you
caught this when we were talking about
your half-yearly diagnosis now the
lecture theater right well you know what
the result is there's there's no bonus
points for actually getting to that
result everything is in the steps so if
you skip any steps especially if they're
very simple ones okay
they're penalized you're pretty bad
because it's obvious that you're going
to arrive there right we want to show
you know for instance I wouldn't get
from here to here and that seems simple
right
but I want to see that okay I'm only
doing one thing from each day to each
step because I could go from here to
here because I know that's what I meant
to end at not because I understand
that's why